عدد من الصحف الاسرائيليه عرض بالتحليل
للعمليه العسكريه التي نفذها الجيش
الاسرائيلي في جنين ولتصدي المقاومه
الفلسطينيه لها وبينما قالت ان جنين اصبحت
تبدو مثل غزه حذرت مما هو متوقع كما قالت
بعد رحيل رئيس السلطه الفلسطينيه محمود
عباس الى اي مدى يقبل الاسرائيليون ما جاء
حتى في صحفهم في اوساط المستوطنين في
الضفه الغربيه المحتله الذين كانوا
يعتقدون بان هذه الحكومه التي توصف بالاشد
تطرفا والاشد يمينيه منذ تاسيس اسرائيل
سوف تغير من الواقع الامني في الضفه
الغربيه المحتله واذ بها لا تاتي باي شيء
جديد على الارض واذ بان العمليات
الفلسطينيه تتصاعد منذ ان تولى بنيامين
نتنياهو دفت الحكومه قبل نحو نصفي
الاسرائيليين متخوفين اكثر من
من تفشي العنف لان نحن نقترب من مرحله ما
بعد محمود عباس وظهور مسلحين لحماس في
الضفه الغربيه ستكون هنالك مواجهات داميه
وجيش الاسرائيلي يعرف ذلك كيف ينظر
الاسرائيليون الى موقف اداره بايدن
المنتقد للاصلاحات القضائيه هنالك من يقول
في داخل المعارضه بان عمليا هذه هي ورقه
رابحه لانها لان تاثيرها ليس فقط على
المدى الداخلي او المدى المنظور على
الديمقراطيه الاسرائيليه بمعنى ان
المعارضه الاسرائيليه تريد ان تقول بان
التغييرات التي يريد احداثها على الجهاز
القضائي في اسرائيل لا تؤثر فقط على
الداخل الاسرائيلي وعلى الديمقراطيه
الاسرائيليه انما تؤثر ايضا على العلاقه
بين اسرائيل ودول العالم وعلى اسرائيل
واهم حليف وشريك لاسرائيل في العالم
[موسيقى]
تقوم بعمل
ترى اداره مايدن انها غير جيده وهي غير
سعيده بها مثل مثل تطوير او بناء
المستوطنات وهذا غير لا يتوافق مع
السياسه مثل معلنه لاداره التي يؤيد حلت
دولتين
وبتصعب ان تتصور كيف تكون دور هناك دوله
فلسطينيه بهذا الوضع ثابت هو انه الموقف
الامريكي لم يتغير كثيرا في العشرين سنه
الماضيه
خطاب هذه الاداره هو
كسابق خطابات في الماضي نرى من المتحدث
الرسمي من الخارجيه بانه يطلب التهدئه
ويقول العنف من الجهتين ولكن
يصف
اعمال المستوطنين
من
الامور الشائكه والسياسات الشائكه في
البيت الابيض وخصوصا في العلاقات بين
الولايات المتحده
واحتلال الاسرائيلي ما هي
الاشياء لتخدير الامور وليست حاسمه راس
راس مال سياسي في هذه العلاقه الذي يغرد
خارج السرب هو حكومه بايدن لان هناك فجوه
كبيره بين ما يقوم به الرئيس بايدن وما
يحدث في الشارع الامريكي كامريكيين وليس
كحكومه لا ارى ان هناك اي مبادره او شيخ
قامت به اداره بايدن فيما يتعلق بما يسمى
عمليه السلام نحو السياسيه الولايات
المتحده انك عدم استقرار متعلق بالسياسه
اتجاهها في اسرائيل وفلسطين وهذه علاقه
معقده جدا
لا اتوقع ان يتحرك ايضا باي عمل فعلي حتى
لو ازداد العنف ووصلنا الى هجوم كبير
اسرائيل على اماكن في الضفه الغربيه
حسابات جو بايدن والحزب الديمقراطي الان
كلها انتخابيه
الولايات المتحده محدوده في قدرتها على ان
تقوم باي تقديم وتحسين العلاقات بين
اسرائيليين والفلسطينيين بشكل مفيد جزء من
ما تحاول ان تقوم به اسرائيل هي نزع
الشرعيه ونزع انسانيه الشعب الفلسطيني لكي
تبرب مجازبها وجرائمها وما نراه في الامم
المتحده هو العكس هو عزل الاسرائيل وهو
اقرار بشرعيه القضيه الفلسطينيه وهي اقرا
بالروايه الفلسطينيه
على نطاق واشنطن ليس من العدل ان تعطى اي
جهه خارجيه
او يعني
الفضل فيما يحدث من ناحيه التوعيه عن
النكبه وما حدث لشعبنا كثير من الناس في
العالم بما ذلك في الولايات المتحده
يبدون القول بان اسرائيل هي نظام فصل
عنصري لقد نسمع هذه الخلافه للطوال الوقت
عندما نعمل على موضوع اسرائيل اداره بايدن
لا ترى اسرائيل بهذه الطريقه
يؤيد اسرائيل اكثر من
الكثير من اعضاء الحزب الديمقراطي انه
الفلسطينيين واقعيا يعني ليس امامهم سوى
خيار العنف ان كان منظما ام اعمال افراديه
وليس امام اسرائيل سوى مزيد من
القمع ليس هنالك اي دبلوماسيه بالنسبه
لبايدن
سياسته المفضله هي فرض عقوبات وقد يصل الى
حد ان يفرض بعض العقوبات الخفيفه اللطيفه
تجاه الحكومه الاسرائيليه الحاليه ويفرض
عقوبات اشد على الشعب الفلسطيني